How do you treat Candida? So any type of yeast infections has to do with an imbalance
of your microbiota. Now there's, we have different nutrients that people take. It really
depends on how chronic this yeast infection is, how stubborn this yeast infection is. Definitely
running some of the Candida programs on the right is important. And then, if you don't want
to start taking another supplements, so I said, Candida program that was very effective.
It is trying to get good probiotics into every orifice of your body. So one of the ways
that you could increase the efficacy of a probiotic supplement is to put it in a culture. So,
let's say yogurt. So let's say you just bought some yogurt. There's enough to be dairy yogurt.
It could be coconut yogurt. Try to stay away from dairy. So you could use coconut yogurt. Just get
it, just get a plain coconut yogurt. If you can find it in an almond milk yogurt or something like that,
that's your culture starter base. Then you could take a capsule of some different probiotics and
it's good to mix up your probiotics. And then put a capsule of that in the yogurt, mix it up,
set it on the counter, let it warm. So the, so the, so the culture can grow the probiotic in there.
It will typically liquefy the yogurt. It'll make it much more runny than if you have like an old
saline, animal thing. You can squirt it up in there if you have some sort of way to
like a little, what do you call it, like a little plunger thing that you can draw up a syringe
that you can draw up that liquid. And then you want to put that in your orifices where you'd put
that in your animal. You would put it up. You're a vaginal track for a female and you could,
you do this in the shower. You'll want to take some of that and swish it in your mouth and let it
kind of dry in your mouth a little bit. It won't dry but you let it coach your mouth. You want to get
that probiotic. If you're just swallowing a probiotic to help with with a Candida infection,
a lot of it is diated with the, with the, with your stomach acid. And it, and you're,
what the survivability is just going to your testicle track anyhow. You have to get it in all your
orifices, even putting it on your hands and letting it dry out your hands and then rinse off and
do this on a regular basis. Those are some of the techniques that you could use for Candida.